[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
hi
hello hello
welcome to the Friendship onion yes we
love it we love a raucous room thanks
for being a raucous room everybody's
drunk by the looks of things done how's
it going
[Applause]
Boston
yeah Boston you threw the first you've
had an amazing time here you threw the
first pitch out of the Boston Red Sox
didn't anyone see that
did very well from the uh from the
pictures Mound I did I went up on the
mound and I threatened it just made it
but you did make it I did make it and
Sean Mr Aston who I think has probably
thrown a first pitch out maybe five or
six times
said to Billy you can move forward
and not no one will really know that's
what people do you move forward about
five or six feet and then you get an
easy way to do it and Billy said no no
no no no no no no no I'm gonna go pro
and you went pro I said I've watched
movies with baseball and the guys always
throw it from that little Hill yeah
I don't know why that hell's there but
they did seem that you do you know why
people don't do it from the hill they're
gone because when you're throwing it
from the hill if you're not used to it
the mound they call it the mound the
pictures it means you're throwing it
down a hill
all right yeah see I never thought of
that and I think that's why a lot of
times when people throw it at bouncies
because it's not actually that far right
everybody talks like you're throwing it
to the moon they're like will you make
it yeah I was like oh how far is it yeah
when when we were in New York like
months ago doing Colbert we were yeah
with Sean Elijah was uh expected his
second child so he couldn't do others
but we were talking at that point about
throwing a pitch out and Sean was like
you'll never do it
it's 60 feet and we were like well how
far away is 60 feet and he was like see
that building over there and we're like
What that can't be
and I asked Billy and he was like no
it's just like
just like this yes it's not actually
that far but everybody makes such a big
thing of it that you start to panic
and you're like oh and then I watch
videos of people doing it and they were
throwing it that way yeah
and it would bounce and stop 50 50 cents
it's famous for doing a terrible one
right and Conor McGregor although you
did tell me you did tell a lie to me
what did I say because before I'd seen
it I said to Billy will you make this
move
foreign
no I basically tossed it like that
I just I wanted it to go at the home
plate you know I didn't want it to go
over there yeah no it was my main thing
yeah yeah of course and I didn't want it
to bounce but I'd forgotten you you did
you did that you threw the first pitch
up it was something else that you did in
Boston that was really I went I went to
the museums and all that I went into the
history no I think that was uh I think
that was it I was in New York and then I
came here for a day and uh I like I kind
of I kind of fell in love with America
Again by being in no like not that I
fell out of love with America but
there's a lot of like there's a lot of
stuff going on you know you're on a
break
I wasn't on a break
but according to these museums and
history and learning about it and and
the Tea Party and in Britain coming with
all these boats and and this new country
trying to invent itself and be brilliant
and and you know like like some some
um
some British troops killed some
bostonians right I don't even know if
they're called bostonians but I think
that's a brilliant word if they're not
they are good they should be
and uh and John Adams I think was the
lawyer for the British guys so they're
they're basically saying you came here
you killed our people but we will try
and and support you in the courts you
know what I mean they were trying to
build a brilliant country and that is a
brilliant country but there's just some
there's a few waves at the moment
as with all countries but looking back
at the history it's amazing you know
yeah incredible
peeling The Onion
thank you
about housekeeping
[Music]
right go on bills you read this first
well wait a minute I'm not gonna glasses
on Tom I can't great because these first
two questions are from people in Boston
so we'll really um Johnny Cruz is quite
good yeah he's really on it just now I
don't know if he stopped drinking or
what he's eating but everything seems to
be going very smoothly so Megan M from
Boston any Megan emson
oh there's a mega name let me is this
let's find out
did you send Dennis and Ann about the
Irish Community
no it's not you then
do you know what Megan you've really
missed a trick there because you could
have just said yes and no no one would
have known and we you'd have been famous
yeah
this is a good one for you actually is
it hey guys I'm sure that you know that
Boston has a massive Irish Community
wondering what your favorite places are
to visit in Ireland or favorite foods of
Ireland or any funny Irish travel
stories well you've been in Ireland
quite a lot yeah Monaghan very strong
Irish name of which I'm sure there's
quite a few Monahans here yeah
um a lot of my family are in Galway
which obviously I've been to was lucky
enough to work in Dublin last year and
what were you making Dom I was making a
show called moonhaven Billy yeah
is anyone watching moonhaven it's INC
plus I actually bought AMC plus just to
watch it yeah
well what a night you had with me
watching the first episode I loved it
yeah I haven't watched the rest yet and
I hear you get your butt out I do I got
my uh buttocks out for I think both of
them yeah both of them yeah I think
for episode three that was a strange day
at work Hotel talk me through it Dom
well they give you options of what you
because you had to be naked you know
what I mean so I said okay how's it work
they said well we'll give you let me
call it something like a modesty shroud
or something
oh you make me feel like Jesus here
that makes it sounds if your Willies
died yeah
which in it well we'll talk about that
later
no the doctor said it's fine I got some
lotion and it's
so it's clearing up
um so so I was like okay so so what are
my options and they said your options
are
you said your options uh we'll put like
a little like a gym towel around you
which which you know you basically have
to hold on to because there's no there's
not enough uh of the rest of the towel
to like you know wrap it around and do
that cool kind of you know nut thing at
the side you're like cocky and stuff so
I was like okay that's a bit weird
and then I said what's the other option
and the other option which I went for
which I honestly think was probably the
worst option was we have a we have a
flesh colored
bag essentially like a shopping bag just
more like um
you know when you get like a bag of
walnuts for Christmas yeah lovely it's
like that right but this is flesh
colored right and you you put you know
your stuff in there right
cram it in
into the corners and stuff and then and
then the way that it attaches is is a
piece of like adhesive tape that goes I
know that that kind of sticks to your
skin just below your belly button and
then the other bit goes in between your
bum cheeks and then goes up and attaches
to the small of your back again with
tape so I was like all right let me try
it so I tried it and then obviously as
soon as you let it go right the gravity
of your genitalia which which is usually
heading south not always no
usually heading
in a southerly direction pushes the tape
off within I would say less than 15
seconds
so I was like well this this doesn't
doesn't work so it didn't it didn't work
you know so essentially I just came out
and said I'm just going to do the towel
thing and they said all right and then
you know the kind of it's weird once the
camera rolls you feel a little
Invincible don't you yeah yeah like when
I was doing Wild Things the amount of
stuff I did during wild things when the
camera was rolling we just think I'm
fine here I'm not gonna die because I'm
on camera and you're like well you could
still definitely die
just means they're going to record it
now which is
even worse and then you know they go and
action and you just drop you just drop
and walk out and I would never do that
I'm quite prudish about mine I know you
are so strangely nakedness
um because I've been I'm sure you've all
been at like whatever parties pool
parties or whatever where they're like
hey we're all going skinny dipping or or
mid-summer I was lucky enough to go to a
mid-summer in Sweden and again if I'm
having a few drinks and then our lovely
host said okay at this point everyone
takes all their clothes off and we all
go jump in the lake and then jump in a
sauna and it was like old people like
80 80 year old men and women yeah all
the way down which for me was when it
got kind of weirder all the way down to
like six seven-year-old kids I know and
they were like we all as a community get
naked and we all jump in the lake and I
said well when you say all
just gonna correct you there because I'm
English and I'm just gonna sit here and
continue to drink vodka and you guys can
do it and there's a there was a great
freedom to that but I I didn't do it
I've never been invited to a party where
people said well let's get naked and
children away
I've got naked once in a film
Tom yeah and they and it was in uh like
a changing room in a swimming pool
and I I it's called on a clear day
and I had someone seen it yeah and uh I
had women's underwear on
for reasons I'll tell you later but but
you mean the character did character
dead and I had to take off these pumps
and nothing so the the you know they
make a thing of it don't they they're
like oh and it's a closed set and no
one's allowed in to say except for
people that have to just a cameraman one
person on sound and the actors and no
one else was allowed in that room and
you're like oh good good in there so we
did like three or four takes of me
taking these women's underwear off and
being naked and I thought you said I
said can I look at the shot just to see
how it looks kind of thing so I went
into the next room where they they were
you know the directors watching on a TV
and everybody else in the set
it's just like that having coffee and
smoking cigarettes and that oh there it
is you're like what's the point of
having a close set if everybody's just
watching on TV oh yeah very strange very
strange well to finish off that question
wait so Ireland yeah oh yeah
it's going to be naked
[Music]
sorry Megan oh no it wasn't you
um
now a word from our sponsor better help
it can be tough to train your brain to
stay in a problem-solving mode when
faced with a challenging life but when
you learn how to find your own Solutions
there's no better feeling a therapist
can help you become a better Problem
Solver making it easy to accomplish your
goals no matter how big or how small
that's right Tom sometimes you just need
to speak to someone about your problems
otherwise you keep them inside and you
can spiral into that problem rather than
thinking about well how am I going to
fix this yeah and it's great to talk to
friends and family but sometimes there's
nothing better than speaking to a
professional and that's what better help
does very very well absolutely if you're
thinking of giving therapy a try better
help is a great option it's convenient
accessible affordable and entirely
online you can get matched with a
therapist after filling out a brief
survey and switch therapists anytime you
like when you want to be a better
Problem Solver therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com onion today and get
10 off your first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash onion
your business can't keep waiting for
your dream hire to sweep you off your
feet how do you find them right now you
need indeed indeed as the hiring
platformer you can attract interview and
hire all in one place don't spend hours
on multiple job sites looking for
candidates with the right skills when
you can do it all with indeed find Top
Talent fast with indeed Suite of
powerful hiring tools like indeed
instant match assessments and virtual
interviews hate waiting indeed U.S data
shows over 80 percent of indeed
employers find quality candidates whose
resumes on indeed matches their job
description the moment they sponsor a
job fantastic yeah I mean if your
responsibility at a business is to be
hiring people and you're on a computer
you can sometimes have 10 windows open
up too much of people and do they do
this
indeed brings it all together they make
it as simple as possible it's absolutely
fantastic the right candidate is doing
everything they can to find you and if
you use indeed you can be sure you're
doing everything you can to find them
too finding great talent doesn't have to
be a second job you can reclaim your
time and find the Talent fast with
indeed indeed knows when you're growing
your own business you have to make every
dollar count that's why when you sponsor
a job you only pay for Quality
applications from resumes in our
database matching your job description
visit indeed.com onion to start hiring
now just go to indeed.com onion
indeed.com onion terms and conditions
apply cost per application pricing not
available for everyone need to hire you
need indeed
uh favorite place in the island so go
away fantastic Dublin where I was lucky
enough to be working and going back
again for season two I really like kill
Kenny really like cork favorite foods of
Ireland
soda bread an Irish butter oh a good
paint again
oh yeah it takes about it takes about 30
minutes to pour that stuff yeah yeah I
went to a bar in a Dublin once in there
I said oh I said this is the best
goodness in the world that you can have
a paint again us and he says do you want
a a slow one or a fast one I was like oh
so it's got to be a slow one hasn't it I
mean if you're here and he goes okay and
he started pulling he said you want a
fast one while you're waiting
[Applause]
oh that's lovely all right thank you
Megan yeah I was once on tour in Ireland
and I went to Belfast
that's a Northern Ireland you see and
there there's a part of Belfast uh or
outside Belfast where they have the
Giants Causeway yeah and it's these
amazing Stones it's unbelievable and
then if you get to the other side of the
water you're in Scotland and those
stones are there as well
and they told us a story about two
giants back in the day dude an Irish
Giant and a Scottish giant who hated
each other and they had a fight and
that's what they broke the the James
Causeway and that's why it's only in
both sides and not right across from
Scotland and I made a little film about
it with the people who were on the cast
and I'll find it and I'll stick it in
the YouTube for um their friendship on
you yeah
as as as I remember it was quite funny
and because it was Giants I used all my
knowledge of special effects I learned
from Lord of the Rings oh brilliant
yeah remember seeing some lovely photos
from that uh shoot from that film shoot
yeah it is an amazing natural phenomenon
I've never been to the Giants Causeway
it's amazing we couldn't go anywhere
because obviously govid was still in a
little bit of lockdown the last time so
I had asked can I can I go to Manchester
to watch you know some football games
and see some family they said
unfortunately no and I said can I drive
anywhere in Ireland and they were like
we'd rather that you didn't because I
really wanted to go to Belfast because
that's a it's amazing City a lot of
history and if Moon Haven goes to a
second season please come visit me and
maybe we'll put you in the show all
right I'm gonna um
here's another question from Sarah C in
Boston is Sarah C here now remember
anyone can be seriously at this point
even you sir
anyway cerasee says I'm a high school
history teacher you love history you
know as you might know the Boston Tea
Party happened here which kickstarted
the course of events that escalates in
the Revolutionary War sorry given that
you're both from the UK and all what's
what's the famous or your favorite piece
of English Scottish history that you
might have learned in school that
completely changed the course of history
well that's a big one there it's a very
big one that changed the course of two
well everything changes of course good
point good point like this right now
it's the it's the butterfly effect isn't
it this is changing all your lives and
you you guys nodding is changing the way
that we're acting right now so you guys
are now also changing history uh like
instinctually I don't know how much it
changed history but I think it did
something there's a relatively iconic
now
football or as you guys say soccer ball
uh game that occurred during the second
world war on I believe Christmas Eve
where the uh Allied troops and the
German officers agreed to not firing
each other uh over the course of a few
hours and instead played a game of
football which I think is just an
incredibly beautiful and romantic kind
of notion about the second world war and
then the day after they all started
killing each other
Merry Christmas but that Merry Christmas
but up to that one day that is
profoundly something very beautiful yeah
they should have just stopped it there
that would have been good yeah
and yeah I I I'm Scottish I don't know
if you've noticed but um in Scotland uh
they we don't we we don't really get our
history because we were um invaded and
taken over by the English here oh yes
and uh so we
so we get all the English History and
stuff and a one story a Scottish story
that I really loved was um
uh Robert Robert the Bruce I think no
Bonnie Prince Charlie
was uh trying to work out how to get
Scotland back from the English and he
went off to the Isle of Skye and he was
sort of hiding in a cave where everybody
was trying to kill him and he thought I
can't do this anymore you know we've
tried hard and it just can't do it and
he watched a little spider making a web
and he'd make it and he'd get almost to
the end and the web would break
and the the spider would go back and
start again and then it break and then
go back and that's where the saying
comes from the effort first you don't
succeed try try again and that was um
Bonnie Prince Charlie
wasn't it yeah
foreign
that's in Massachusetts
um
which is a difficult difficult state
what
there's one in Hampshire as well of
course is that New Hampshire oh
old Hampshire
Salem yeah which is here in Salem we're
known for our witches if you could put a
spell on each other what would it be
and here's a bonus
what's your favorite movie Witches does
Galadriel qualify as a witch oh I don't
think Elijah's a witch well that's
that's three questions Elven princess
which you know what is a witch I mean I
know she had gone through that moment of
like if I had the ring and stuff got
dark I could potentially look like I
would be as powerful
which is which is much more witchy at
that point but I wouldn't necessarily
class Galadriel as a witch
um I kind of like the idea of witches
because I think
you know we you know as as the way
history is gone men have been in power
for a long time and I think it's time
for women to be in power right
but here's the here's the little bit of
this
for women to get in power real power
just now I feel like they have to
sometimes be too masculine
and we don't want we want to be more
witchy you know I want to maybe feminine
that's strong femininity yeah yeah but
not have to wear trouser suits and yeah
I've got to be a man to be a powerful
woman yeah you know I just we need more
feminine energy is very very powerful
and very yeah I mean
I totally uh agree with you on that one
but Tom if you were to Put a Spell on Me
Put a Spell on You I was lovely though
man thank you I was good though well I
thought right I've not thought this
through because it's the first time I
read this question but my thing would be
because you do you do point at me a lot
my spell would be when you point at me
yeah another miniature hand comes out
right and then an index finger comes out
of that hand and continues to point into
Infinity until you stop pointing at me
I'd like that so it just
I'd like that because then you would
calm it down with the point there's a
lot of accusatory Point did you eat my
breakfast have you given me that twenty
dollars you owe me that would be my
spell what about you you're trying to
make me more beautiful I you know what I
would spell I would give you the spell
of
being able to understand and talk to all
animals oh great
great I don't it's a good spell I don't
think we'd ever see you again that
wasn't the reason for this bill I think
you'd just be strong about the garden
talking to ants and all that squirrels
and stuff yeah why are you all in a row
while we're all following him well who's
he he's at the front oh
well if he was at the front and we'd
follow him all right
the smell of lemon oh no
we were talking last night weren't we
briefly about nature and all that kind
of stuff and like it is it is kind of
like the closest thing to like a
quote-unquote spiritual practice for me
that connection to Nature so that's a
wonderful spell yeah I thought that was
good probably better than a hand coming
out of my finger but maybe not
I think we go over the page now because
I think we well why don't we take one or
two questions here what should we do
that because there's people here yeah
come on if anyone's got a question of
course I didn't want to be so
presumptuous
well
what's your name and where'd you come
from
Manchester New Hampshire
for Manchester United yeah well
brilliant we're not very original
wow
there's a whip sorry to stop me there
for a second there's a weird thing in
the United States where sometimes if you
go into like Bed Bath and Beyond for
instance or something like that all the
Linens and the and the bed sheets are
called Manchester and that's because
obviously Manchester was famous for
creating textiles no I didn't know that
yeah so that section in the in the shop
is like oh the Manchester section yeah
they're all condos now oh is that right
Bed Bath and Beyond got me as soon as I
arrived brilliant oh my God yeah any
store that says and 20 off yeah yeah I'm
like what yeah yeah I'll buy everything
is 20 off yeah that's fantastic anyway
where is New Hampshire Tom oh my hand
was safe for instance yeah the United
States of America yeah
over here is California yeah my thumb is
Florida Florida up here we have New York
water water Canada
Mexico
where is New Hampshire
[Laughter]
[Music]
Kim for instance we were in Boston yeah
and make what was your Becky Becca Becca
Becca see for instance Becca hasn't
traveled that far okay
I'm going to say
here
little little over here
keep going north until the other way
Walk This Way
[Music]
[Applause]
Up Up
close I mean come on
pretty cool it's quite hard around here
there's a lot of little ones yeah
there's tiny Stakes around here I
remember when my son had my son
my son had the jigsaw of the United
States and all around this bit's the
hardest bit because there's a lot of
little bits a lot of little pieces it's
all right when you go further in the Big
Blocks spring boom boom but all around
here oh there's a lot of history
so my question's for Billy oh
[Laughter]
well I love you both in Lord of the
Rings of course but I've recently I saw
you in season four of Outlander where
you play one of Brianna's suitors yes
and my question is have you read The
Outlander books before you took that
role well that's a good question
I tell you what I read the first one
it's filthy is it
foreign
guy on a horse
she's like in the stone no she travels
through the stone not everyone can right
the big Scotty's going horse can right
he's stuck where he is right but she's
then and in rural Scotland with this big
guy
intense and no one will know no no no no
no
so you've not read the books no I
I did read the first one and then I
skipped ahead to Forbes to be honest
um but
I really enjoyed I don't know why I
didn't continue I think because I was
filming it quite soon so I was just like
oh I need to get through this so I
haven't went back and um and and
finished the rest but I will they're uh
they're great stories you did a good job
oh thank you very much and his hair
always hair in that project I love you
with a ponytail you've never had one in
real life have you well not since 1984.
it really it genuinely suits you that
and my mum and dad said the same thing
they said that's the best hair that I've
ever seen on Billy I said you didn't
realize that's not real hair I don't
think I think my pony do these Pony pony
days trying to is that for me would you
ponytail wearing days ponytail wearing
days are gone I'm sorry that's all right
I like your tastes and shirts thanks for
your support thanks for everyone's
support for wearing friendship on your
Merchants thank you and I am maiden of
course
what what's your name sir and where'd
you come from uh my name is Dylan and
I'm from Pennsylvania
thumb line yeah what earlier raps are
your wrist yeah
East Coast yeah the start of my lifeline
yeah yes yeah that's what we're known
for right yeah
uh my question was have you ever
considered doing a gene and Denver Dave
edition of eat the world
oh that would be a fun mom well we'd
have to look at the ages
of who's in the room we enjoyed Jean in
Denver Dave and I think Billy and I do
Gene and Denver Dave quite a lot but
honestly we we always wanted and
continued to want the the podcast to be
something that anyone can listen to and
there has been a few times where you
know mums and dads have said it's funny
but unfortunately
you know the kids are saying why are
there 15 bleeps in 10 seconds
we get it so I mean maybe yeah I think
we should I think we should probably do
as an extra maybe yeah we'll do some
extras for Gina Denver Dave I do like
Jean and Denver Dave yeah so I think we
all do
thanks Dylan it was awesome to talk to
you thanks hey thanks very much
another friendship onion t-shirt how's
it going it's so comfortable oh there
you go thank you not paid just
freedom of speech there freedom of
speech I'm Catherine Catherine from
Rhode Island
both of you that's okay uh individually
separate
um Billy you've talked about how you
love dancing which I love because I'm a
dancer yes 20 years what is that like do
you just like put on music and groove or
yeah totally normally the kitchen I've
got um you know Sonos where you it's
like speakers you can put around the
house and then you choose where you want
the music yeah so it's normally Kitchen
in the morning and it not definitely on
pancake days days when I have pancakes
because that takes a bit of time and
then I just put on something uh and then
and then I start to dance and my
favorite thing when I'm dancing is if I
find a new move that I've never done
before whoa then I'll just repeat it and
repeat it and then I'll shout on my wife
and say you want to try this
and get her to try the move because if
she sees the move she'll do the move so
I love that the only thing it sometimes
goes wrong is my son's got a Sonos in
his bedroom and sometimes I accidentally
press that one
so I'll you know I'll have on you know
music from Saturday Night Fever or
something it's 6 30 in the morning he's
not too happy about that
I love it and uh during covid obviously
when when the lockdown was pretty strict
I wasn't seeing Billy at all and uh
Billy would send me the occasional kind
of dance my way because yeah because he
knows that I liked it and to be honest
sometimes I would text Billy and say
kind of having a bit of a rough day I
mean I'm having a bad time I wasn't I
was fine
because I knew if I said that an hour or
so later he'd be like okay watch me do
an Electric Boogaloo for you which is
brilliant so I've saved all those and
that might be another thing that we get
on the Friendship audience good idea
Billy dancing uh in a happy fashion is a
wonderful thing
quick questions you know
I love all your work that I've seen in a
while
tops the list learned so many things
about so many cool animals I'm curious
um what was the most challenging Wild
Things adventure and what was your
favorite if you can pick if you can yeah
there's a lot of I mean at any time I'm
working with animals it's amazing you
know I used to be kind of a night owl
and then have become an early riser but
even when I was still a night owl and
did not enjoy going up early in the
morning waking up early in the morning
for Animals was something I would just
spring out of bed to do I just
absolutely loved it and still do to this
day is
it's a real like bonus kind of thing in
my life
um most challenging I guess you could
look at in different ways in terms of
like
what was the closest that I was to being
in genuine kind of peril and danger we
you know we were almost my entire crew
was almost all trampled by an African
elephant which was genuinely really
scary I was not the slowest in the group
so I remember thinking well
it was Frank probably gonna get Frank
first and then Dave
and then it's Mike and then it's
probably me so as soon as I hear Mike in
trouble then I really need to get my
skates on but that was scary and then in
terms of most dangerous I mean like the
irakanji jellyfish which you could argue
is like the most venomous animal on the
planet you know we were in the open
ocean with these creatures just in front
of your face and if a if a current hits
you or hits the jellyfish in a way that
you weren't expecting and it comes
towards your mask and you know gets on
your face you can easily be dead in you
know less than a minute and um so that
was kind of interesting black mamba's
interesting black mum is the most
intelligent snake I've worked with I
mean you know reptiles are intelligent
in different ways but
a lot of them don't tend to show it too
often but with the black mamba
um you can I I could watch it problem
solving in real time so I was holding it
by its tail obviously to keep it close
to me and it was you could see it going
okay I can't go left because there's
someone there and I can't go that way
because he's got hold on my tail now I
could bite his hand and then I could you
can see it kind of like kind of like
figuring stuff out and it started to
look over my shoulder and I said to the
snake Handler that I was also working
with I was like how come it's looking
over my shoulder I've never seen a snake
not look just directly at me and the
Handler's saying it's trying to figure
out once it bites you and you're
incapacitated and now you can't move you
can't you know there's nothing else you
can do what is ahead of it as a
potential for escape and stuff they're
just a very very smart animal so I think
those are the most challenging and then
favorites they're all my they're all
really hard to pick because hanging
around with dangerous animals is a real
thrill to me and something that I love
um
I don't know I mean swimming with whale
sharks was pretty special I mean it
literally like came over to me and the
person who we were working with was like
you're not legally allowed to kind of
touch them you know they have to do
their own thing we're like okay so I'm
just like in the water with my hands up
like this and it came over to me and
like Len it's dorsal fin next to me yeah
it was amazing and slowed down and so my
hands like this and as soon as my hand
held onto its door something then it
started to pick up speed but it's never
moving its tail in a really drastic
fashion to harm you it's just slightly
moving itself because it's like well
I've got a human on my back and I was
like this is incredible that this animal
is so sensitive to my needs you know so
I think that was kind of stand out wow
thanks thank you guys thank you
hi hi I'm Julia I'm from Washington DC
good uh Billy it was awesome seeing you
at Awesome Con a couple years ago when
you came down and and ended the
convention so it's nice to see you again
was that Washington yes it was
Washington Washington DC DC you know we
had fun Maryland and Maryland and all
that yes and Washington DC isn't a state
right not right now no okay okay there
you go um so my question is who was the
easiest to pull a prank on on the Lord
of the Rings set because it seemed last
night at the special panel that most of
us got to go to which was amazing
um you had fun winding up both uh Sean
and Elijah even before getting on stage
so who it doesn't have to be either one
unless it is but who was the easiest to
pull a prank on on the Lord of the Rings
set I mean at the Sean and Elijah are
both like child's player yeah oh they
are
adorable people and that's one of the
most adorable things about them is they
just take you on your word but you know
I Billy and I can just say anything and
they'll be like really you go I would
see probably
mostly Elijah I think mostly Elijah
likes to think that people are telling
them the truth yeah you can also watch
each other's minds because Sean didn't
try and believe you that you could read
each other's minds I know yeah yeah he
did he did believe that and like Billy
said he was backing us when people come
over and go well that's not possible
telepathy's not really been proven he
was like but these guys can do it I've
seen it it's a it's a strange thing
because like with the European let's say
let's just take the fellowship for
example with the European members of The
Fellowship of which I would put Vigo in
there because obviously he has Danish
Heritage spent a lot of time in Spain
and stuff you can't do that with Vigo
you just can't he he just kind of looks
at you like
[Music]
you're [ __ ] with me right
Sean Bean the same yeah Ian McKellen the
same but when you move over to the
people from the United States there's a
there's a what there's a wonderful I I
genuinely do think it's a wonderful
personality trait as a sweeping
generalization in the country is that
you guys do tend to take people on their
word you're like okay if that's what
you're saying then we're gonna trust
that that's true and it's generally not
with you enough no no which is
absolutely lovely I remember there was a
publicity the head of publicity girl
Claire uh and she met you one morning
when you went into work and morning
morning Dom morning where's belly and he
said Billy's dead and
she was like oh my God
yeah
yeah she was devastated
and head of publicity so she said we got
to put something out we gotta
what time what time what happened what
happened I was like no no he's not
really dead
it's just a joke ah anyway thank you for
your question thank you you really
they're filthy as always
I think I think we don't have time for a
tongue twister I think we probably just
have to eat the world we have to eat
that we can't come in Boston and not
let's see
Billy and Dom eat the world now look at
this ladies and gentlemen we're eating
cannolis
cannolis
hey you can always thank you so much
cannolis I had no idea that the cannoli
was a thing from Boston yesterday
so we're we're actually doing two
warring cannolis yeah which I'm sure you
guys will know about what are the two
companies William no with anyone in here
no
mics mics mics can always and
bovas
oh there's a clap over there oh hey
and we'll be the judges of that
and your name is what Bova Emily Bova
she's like that's the winner
Billy I'm gonna jump into a tiny little
thing about cannolis and could you maybe
be mother well I'll do that do you guys
know what being mother is at me which is
slightly sexist to be fair when
someone's you know in Britain may be
serving cakes or tea and they say shall
I be mother that means shall I serve the
cakes and the tea I know isn't that
sexist you should say something like
it's also sexy it is quite sexy I know
the history of the cannoli is a
reflection of the variety of cultures
and people that throughout the centuries
have inhabited Sicily as a strong symbol
representing Italian Heritage the
cannoli has a unique and Rich history
the traditional version of the cannoli
originated in Palermo
Italia in this time Sicily was under
Arab rule making traditional food stands
was was important for the locals so many
accounts point to the Sicilian city of
Palermo lovely thank you but the filling
may have first been created by ancient
Arabic people so it's a combination of
those two things sometimes the hamsters
at um like um giving us more oh this is
for the audience I'm going to give love
to some people in the audience here
because we've got quite a lot of canola
here as a show of hands in the audience
um
how many people regularly eat a cannoli
oh it's all kinds of people eat a
cannoli just just under half the orders
I mean it's a it's a rich kind of cake
right made famous in The Godfather first
Godfather film obviously uh leave the
gun take the cannoli which is a famous
line one of the most famous lines in
that in that film
um and you you and I only had our first
ever cannoli the last time we were here
do you remember not not in Boston but
the last time we did a convention there
were actually ever having a canola and
what you were saying about like Middle
East and what are you doing I'm making
cannoli
I would say put them all on one plate
and the people can just come you're
doing it individually oh my God
what's going on now I'm sure that they
can try the one each right go on camera
the lovely people are at Fan Expo lovely
people at Fan Expo actually got us all
all got the people backstage some
cannolis to try and we love them didn't
we are you off out
I'll do a little bit more reading um
now what what do you guys want to know
who invented the first cannoli or what
is in the name cannoli which is what's
the most interested who invented the
first or the name
the name the name will do the name
in Italian
cannoli is a plural name whose singular
form is a canola so if you have one
canola it's this and then these are
cannolis it is a diminutive of Kana
which means a
which means a cane-like reed such as
sugar cane the form cannolis has a very
rare plural form but also canola is
widely accepted as a singular form these
delicious dishes and our favorites all
over Italy and Boston
where they are known as
cannoli
siciliani meaning Sicilian cannolis
and then it says here what does a river
Reed have to do with the pastry the key
is in the shape early pastry chefs used
to use these Reeds to shape their dough
before putting them in oil to fry
amazing nowadays for hygienic reasons
you won't find cannolis made with River
Reeds no even in the most authentic
Italian restaurants I would think they
would use something metallic yeah canes
have been replaced replaced by special
steel cylinders lovely William they're
probably more healthy in Practical chefs
at Italian Villa use metal tubes which
are a lot more sanitary that's kind of
boring well what should we eat has
everyone as people in the crowd got a
choice of a cannoli as well right yeah
so this is Mike's this is Mike's cannoli
which our past mates cannoli uh down at
the sort of it seems like an Italian
part of town
it looks amazing what's the best
restaurant there
pizza that's a restaurant called Pizza
I'm going now yeah I wonder what they
serve
now would it is what's the best kind of
classic drink with the cannolis it
canolean coffee canolian tea what's up
espresso you say lovely Italian I'd like
to have an espresso actually Tom she's
good it was good what are you doing
makes Mike's but it's very it's very
rich very nice but there's there's a
cinnamon I'm not ah you don't like
cinnamon yeah but hey Billy's ability to
um sniff out or taste cinnamon is
profound because we'll we'll be eating
something and I'll say what you think
you'll say too much cinnamon in that and
I'll say I can't taste any cinnamon I've
got a very refined palette maybe that's
uh your superhero power or a spell but I
thought it was my finger becomes a hand
and then a finger
right I was scoring these individually
or as a group and I need to take the
other one all right what's the other one
called right hold on this is uh
bovas which the young lady over there
absolutely loves
it's easier to remember mics oh so I
would I would say right the Bova one
yeah comes with a dark chocolate which
is already a little extra that this guy
Mike's don't have which he's gonna cheat
do you know what I mean but let's see um
oh
laughs
oh God
[Applause]
do you prefer that one no I'm not
telling you yet
does everyone else enjoying their
cannolis
I'm going to just try the inside of the
cannoli yeah the cannoli cream
[Music]
I'm gonna say
hang on
okay hold on Bova
oh I'm torn
I'm torn because I think I like the
cream in one but the pastry in another
oh God I know
it's quite contrary isn't it I'm going
to try the piece I'm getting really into
this this isn't like I'm not messing
around here I'm not trying to entertain
you people I'm honestly trying to work
out what's the best to know it
Mike's founded in 1946
I'm trying to find out when when bovis
were founded but I've got no information
there any idea oh wait 1926. 26 20 years
earlier so they're the oldest
all right well let's give it some scores
when was the first World War
1914 is that right well done tremendous
knowledge no I'm good
um right are we for God's sake can you
answer this question
are we scoring them individually or as a
group this is like three or four times
and
flavor taste no it's your individually
together okay so taste for Boba and Mike
make and then Boba okay this is a tough
one because I prefer the filling in mics
but the pastry in the Bova but I'm gonna
go mics
a
over 8.2
. it's a tough one
make
1.5
over
9.2 oh you loved it
you loved it
aesthetic well Aesthetics I think
unfortunately because Bova came with
kind of a dipped
dark chocolate and it's just a little
more pleasing on the eye don't you think
wouldn't you say well I don't know well
so for me that's I'm gonna give the Bova
seven and the mics are six because you
know it's kind of a sausage shaped
nothing well I had to write home about
no I like the ship
and uh I think it's a very attractive
thing I can only and um but
I think make looks more like a classic
cannoli which I want a cannoli look like
that's true I'd agree with that so I'm
going to give make
an 8.5 on Aesthetics right
but bolva I'm only given because they
messed around with it too much
7.8 yeah because Mike's looks like the
boat the uh cannoli in The Godfather
film and that's the one that you kind of
want is one we all want to be in the
garden it doesn't taste as good yeah
now usefulness how useful is a cannoli
I'm sure you must is there a cannoli ice
cream flavor yeah you guys have that
here would you do like a cake so you
could put cannoli on top of a cake
you can only chips cannoli chips really
what make them savory
ice cream yeah there's the spoon love
that
a creme creme brulee cannoli at bothas
that's the tongue twister right there
yeah I love a creme brulee I do love a
creme bruh has it got a hard top on it
oh is it as it's solid on the top can
you crack it yeah that defines a creme
brulee yeah I know it defines it but
sometimes people will mess with things
as we notice with the bow vacuole yeah
well it's quite useful also relatively
portable you know you can like hold it
in your hand maybe put five or six of
them in the tupperware box bring it to a
football game if you've got a good
triangle
triangle rectangle
if you've got a good shaped rectangle
box two cannolis wide and five can
always long brilliant you could fit
easily 28 cannolis yeah
that's but I think they are quite useful
kids love them old people love them
people love them
you people have loved them since 1928
and and before I think it's a usefulness
score for the two of them because yeah
because they're both kind of the same
I'm going to give it a usefulness score
of
I'll give it an eight that's quite good
though I can say it's that useful I mean
I mean
I'll I'll give that a 7.2 I'll give her
7.2 but it's a good that's a couple of
good cannolis we're just going to take
the inside of this one
well we're getting close to being
Running Out of Time guys if you are
hanging out for the rest of the
convention and you come in to see either
Bill you're right today and you did have
a question that we didn't get a chance
to answer it please come out ask us it
when we're signing stuff for you thanks
for all your support thanks for wearing
the t-shirt and the merch thanks for
listening to the show
thank you thank you we really appreciate
it of course you can get in touch with
us in all the ways that you want and
even if you don't listen to this show or
your friends don't listen to the show
just getting to subscribe because the
more people subscribe the more we can
pancake because we don't want to get to
a point where we say oh guys we can't
make it yeah and you're off you're off
in Ireland doing whatever exactly hey
thanks a lot for coming thanks for being
so supportive and we'll see you around
thank you thank you
thanks very much enjoy the rest of the
convention thanks for coming
[Applause]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
[Music]